Speaker 1: David Pakman dot com slash discord
is how you can jump in and talk to me.
Let's speak next to Gio from Juarez.
Speaker 3: Hello there. Yes. Okay, I'm from
Mexico, and I also wanted to read from the last
time Eric from Cancun called about the El Paso
shooting, and so I'm also a bit worried about
what could happen in the if I go to the U.S..
OK, I'm from Paris, I'm from the border
of Mexico, and it's it's really worrying
to myself because I used to travel a lot
to the year before the pandemic. Actually,
the international roads have been closed in
March 2020 and they will open for the first
time in November this year, supposedly. So
I am also a bit worried about if I should
be prepared for a shooting or something.
Speaker 1: OK. Well, I mean, listen, it's
just about your personal risk assessment. I would
research where you're going and determine whether.
It's suitable for your level of risk. I
mean, I can't possibly answer the question,
is it safe for you to go to the U.S., you know?
Speaker 3: Yeah, because you know, you say the
the shooting that happened in the Paso, in the
Walmart is actually a Walmart. Me and my mother
used to go up and actually I with it and planned
to go on the day that it happened. But a friend
was there. A friend of mine said they didn't
suffer anything, but we just got a little bit
is the end of and scared of loud noises. I don't
know if that's still the case, but yeah, it's
a bit worrying. Just want us to share. Yeah, I
Speaker 1: mean, listen, the odds of you being
killed in a shooting are very, very low, although
still higher than in many other countries, right?
So, you know, it's a very personal decision.
Speaker 3: OK, well,
I just wanted to ask your opinion on that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's really it's I can't
possibly advise you on that. I think. All right,
my friend, thank you very much for the call.